um
today we are going to continue um
thinking about reactions um
just to remind you what did we do on
friday so we introduced here's what we
did last time
we talked about constant we talked about
reactions okay and there
on on friday we were really interested
in rates
you know how fast is it happening so we
talked about things that affect the
reaction rate
right like concentration okay
concentration versus time
and and how you can measure that and
then and and you can have
rate laws based on experimental
measurements
okay and and and that that can tell you
the reaction order
we talked about zeroth first second
order reactions uh the rate constant
and then we also talked about the
temperature dependence
um and the very end the role of a
catalyst and lowering that
activation barrier today
we're going to talk about how things
dissolve so we're going to talk about
solubility okay
and this has to do with reactions
because
something dissolving is a reaction
but but what's going to happen is we're
going to talk about how that reaction
finds its happy place and we know
happy place is a good thing and and it's
called equilibrium
right uh and so that's going to involve
talking about things like
oh equilibrium constants uh the
dissolution
we're going to look at some examples
with ionic compounds so salts we're
going to be dissolving salts in
in water and and looking at how to think
about
how much of that dissolves in terms of
the equilibrium constant for the
reaction
okay so that's the goal today i want to
start though
uh by talking about why this matters
and that's directly related to your
goody bag
okay so this is uh this is
something some of you may have seen uh
the data here
from the 50s is from the mauna loa
measurements the top of the volcano
and uh and and this is co2 concentration
parts per million in the atmosphere
and but if you dig into the ice you know
we're gonna be doing a lot of that here
in boston over the next three months
but if you dig deeper into the ice in
the cores
you go back in time it's a beautiful
thing
the ice as you go down is ancient
atmosphere
that's cool because there's little
bubbles remember like like
you know there remember we talked about
like the half-life of carbon 14
that's trapped from say a living thing
breathing it in
right well you can trap directly the
little bubbles of atmosphere
in the ice and that's what happens and
that's why we know what co2 levels were
going back a million almost a million
years here it's 800 thousand years of
data
and uh this is a graph that i think many
of you see if we can't you know
so so okay it's going up a lot right
okay uh and here it is now this is just
zooming in on the last
uh uh 50 years so this is just the data
the monolith
load data uh and and the reason is
because here we also have another kind
of data so there's a lot of attention
paid
on co2 and there should be there's a lot
less attention paid to what that is
doing
to our oceans and this is a reaction
that we will talk about more
when we talk about acidification so when
we talk about acids and bases which is
coming up later
later being wednesday and next week
we'll talk more about this but i just
want to tell you that when when you have
co2 in the atmosphere going up
then you also have co2 in the ocean
going up so the co2 in the ocean co2 in
the
atmosphere
is getting absorbed by the ocean
okay so what no it's it's a lot
of what because what happens is
the co2 in the ocean the more co2 in the
ocean
is making the ocean more acidic now so
so if you if you just write this number
down because it's
so astonishing
okay past
past 200 years
the ocean has become
30 percent more acidic
now that is the faster fastest
fastest known change
fastest known change in the ocean
chemistry in
50 million years
okay
that's a big and very sudden change
so the ocean is is absorbing about 22
million tons per day
of co2 and that number is going to say
well okay why does that matter
isn't it again maybe it'll do the oceans
what it's doing to the atmosphere making
things a little more
no it's doing more because when it
acidifies
then it has a direct impact on things
like this
which is a a terror pot and this is one
of
you you look at the the food chain of
the ocean there's like three things at
the bottom
that's one of them i mean there's plants
right there's there's photosynthesis and
then there's the bottom
of the food chain now you know what
what's going to happen when the bottom
of the food chain
uh disappears right this is one of
one of the main kinds of animals that
lives at the bottom of which
they've got these very small calcium
carbonate shells
if you make the ocean just a little more
acidic
like we're doing those shells don't
survive
and those animals don't survive right
so that's what happens to a pteropod
at the rate we're going in like
decades of time from now that's what
happens right
45 days so what you have in your goodie
bag
is a way to see this a little bit more
accelerated
right so so here's your goodie bag okay
so i wanted you to
i wanted you to see what's happening in
the ocean
and you have now the tools to do that so
in your goody bag you've got
uh citric powder imagine you take a lot
of limes and you squeeze them and then
you dry it all out and that's what you
got
right citric acid okay now you're gonna
mix that
with water to change the ph and that's
going to so you're going to dissolve
this powder
that's the topic of today's lectures
dissolution right in equilibrium
so you're going to mix that into water
and you've got a scale
from a previous goodie bag
so my hope is that you've been using
that on a daily basis you take it with
you places
and you can use that again here and
you'll need that because i want you to
see
how these shells dissolve and if you
lower
the acidity more you know you we we
don't want to wait 40 but you can't wait
45 days but i want to i want you to be
able to do these experiments in minutes
so we're going to go a little lower in
acidity in ph
right but you're going to get the same
result you're going to dissolve these
shells
okay now this is okay now uh
please some of you are going on planes
and
there's white powder and a scale
involved in this goodie bag
please don't put that in your carry-on
it's just not a good it really isn't a
good idea like we have data
from students sending me pictures
with the airport screening person
so i i love the excitement of
thinking about this over thanksgiving
but put it in your suitcase
if you're gonna take it home okay that's
my why this matters
well so we're dissolving stuff today
that's the topic how do things dissolve
yeah there's a citric powder that's
citric
acid that's gonna make water more acidic
and again we're going to move into acids
and bases next they were just talking
about dissolution
and so here's here's citric acid there
it is now over thanksgiving i thought
i'd throw this in because you might have
sugar
at the table you know to call it
c12h22o11
don't ask for the sugar if you want to
add some sugar to something
ask for it by molecular name now but the
question is why do these things dissolve
in the first place
there's acetic acid citric acid
um uh there's sugar right these are
molecules that look like that
why did they dissolve in the first place
and the answer
is because of all the things that we've
learned
about bonding right and about things
like
like whether a molecule is polar or not
or in this case whether you've got the
possibility
to hydrogen bond or not
right and so if you look at both of
these that you can see
that they both have a whole bunch of
little oh groups
that look a whole lot like things we've
seen
that like to hydrogen bond all right you
see those ohs on the end there
both for sugar right around the outside
and for citric acid and and so what
happens is if
i put a sugar molecule into water here's
a picture of it
okay there's a picture of it so there's
sugar molecules there now they start in
a crystal of sugar
right little you know you pour your
sugar in a teaspoon of sugar
and and then and it's in a solid but
then it goes off and it breaks away
into the water and those those little
ones are the water molecules
why because the water was bonding to
itself
the water has dipoles dipole-dipole
remember that the water has
uh hydrogen bonds
but the sugar does too the sugar does
too
and so the water sees this this crystal
of sugar and it says well hang on
you know if you come out um we we could
bond together
in much the same way that we're already
bonding with each other the water
molecules are already bonding
hydrogen dipole sugar is like well i got
hydrogen i got dipole
and and so it can break off and it
doesn't cost
that much energy in fact it gains energy
by doing this
right it can gain and so this can
actually be
a lower energy state overall
now that's because
of something that many of you
have probably heard and now we can put
some bonding to it but it's because like
dissolves like oh yeah that's technical
that's technical because now we know
what like means like means a type of
bonding
right like means a type of so there you
go it's like
water it has hydrogen bonding potential
therefore
it's able to dissolve in the water
right so water water has
well what does water have it's got
dipoles
right so it can do dipole-dipole stuff
it's got h-bonds
oh everything has london
everything has london right
yeah so if you got those ingredients if
you got that ability
if you got those likes then you might be
able to dissolve
okay well this is called a polar solvent
because the molecules that make it up
are polar
right okay they've got dipole you know
actually and
and so we're very interested in in
understanding how things mix with other
things and why they mix with other
things
um let's take a look at another example
right
so here we have ethanol i keep on
bringing up ethanol
there might be some served and if you're
21 or over you can have some
otherwise it's illegal
ethanol up there at the top thank
goodness
you will say at your thanksgiving table
it is not methoxymethane
and because if it were it would be the
same chemical formula
but the oh the o would be in the middle
of the two c's with the ch3s on the ends
and it wouldn't be able to hydrogen
bonding or all this be vapor
it'd be vapor no but it's ethanol
because it has hydrogen bonding
capabilities but look at what happens if
it's heptanol so all i've done now is
i've taken the same
n group and i've given it more of a
carbon chain
how is that going to affect how it
dissolves given what we just talked
about that like dissolves
but they both have hydrogen bond
potential
they both have high but look more and
more of it as you go from methanol to
heptanol
more more and more of it is something
else
it's only london
so what's going to happen now if i put
this in the water
well we can see let's go in series
here's methanol
ethanol propanol right butanol pentanol
hexanol heptanol is down at the bottom
and there's the water
solubility all we got to write that down
solubility solubility
okay so solubility is
kind of what it sounds like the ability
for a solute
that's the thing we're dissolving
okay to dissolve
in a solvent
that's the thing we're trying to
dissolve it into
that's the solubility and we'll be
talking about the maximum solubility in
just a few minutes which is what we
usually
say what's the solubility we often mean
the maximum
well that's what's listed here the
maximum right so what
okay oh okay uh methanol ethanol
miscible
so you can put as much as you want and
it'll always
get you know keep mixing in with the
water but now look
once you get to butanol pentanol hexanol
it starts going down
you can't mix as much as you want in
fact it's less and less and less and the
reason
we now know is because of what i just
said
right as you go down the hydrogen bond
and dipole dipole-dipole
becomes less important because you've
got more and more of the molecule
that's only london and so it's less
like the water environment the bonding
environment that the water liked
with itself and so it has
more of a trouble more trouble
dissolving and being energetically
favorable
isolated by those water molecules by the
way does anybody know the origin
of the word proof speaking of ethanol
if you buy a bottle of ethanol uh
at the at the supermarket okay so
there's gin
or vodka or whatever and and it says
it's something percent out here 20
alcohol 40 proof
does anybody know where that comes from
it's this it's just
but what they did they didn't know if
you were making good alcohol back at the
time
and they said well i don't i don't have
all these detailed abilities to measure
and quantify it so
i'm just going to light it on fire that
is exactly what
p is this a good bottle of gin i don't
know
let's light it on fire
that's what they did and it turns out
that if ethanol and water
are at 50 50 mixture or more
it will light on fire don't try that
please
don't do these experiments but so
that meant that mint is this a good
bottle of gin
well if it's 50 50 i'm gonna say it's a
good bottle of gin
so let's light it on fire oh it lit on
fire that's 100
proof that it's good
that is true that is the origin of the
word proof
it is proof that it's mixed well
and it's good stuff okay
mix dissolution dissolution
oh what else can we try to dissolve okay
we're dissolving alcohol we're going
down to heptanol we're lucky it's not
methoxy methane
um we talked about sugar you know so
we got to have a framework by the way so
okay solubility the ability for solute
to dissolve
and now okay there's a context here
right let's suppose i'm dissolving
sugar right so so sugar
how are we going to write this
dissolving down
well sugar is c12 okay
h22011
and and if we put it in water well you
know we could we could formally write
the whole thing out
right we can write it out we can say
well i'm going to add water to it
right
and that's going to go to well okay it's
going to go to c12
plus more water but there's something
very important that i'm leaving out
and when you think about dissolution you
got to keep track
what was it was it a solid was it a
liquid or was it something dissolved in
a liquid
right so this started as a solid so we
put an s there
this started as a liquid this is the
dissolved thing so we put an aq
and the aq means aqueous it is in an
aqueous solution it is a dissolved
molecule
right and so and so here this is a
liquid now the other thing that
that happens
is well okay the h2o is kind of there
it's
it's all over the place it's the solvent
and
and so we often leave it out because
it's everywhere on both sides right
and so often what you'll see and we'll
write more of these
coming is that you might write a
dissolution
of sugar as this
solid and it just goes to something
that is dissolved
and you know that what happened there is
sometimes you'll also see it like this
what'd you do on the arrow i added water
that's what the arrow did okay so i'm
just
just getting comfortable with writing
these dissolution reactions
okay now what else can i dissolve well
here's another good example vitamin a
vitamins
there's some vitamins you can have as
much as you want pretty much
why because they're water soluble
and other vitamins are fat soluble that
means they they
they just they don't like water as much
as they like the hydrophobic
hydrophobic molecules of fat cells
and so they go into fatty tissue
where they don't come out that's why
don't have do not have unlimited amounts
of vitamin a
that's not good for you but vitamin c
no problem no problem because it's going
to dissolve in water
right and so your body can take in and
get rid of as much of it as you want but
not
get if it's dissolved in fat cells
that's a different thing so vitamin a
vitamin c and you can see it right there
from the chemistry
this is it look at all those oh groups
in vitamin c
look at that oh that's gonna love
hydrogen bonding
and on vitamin a you just got the one
all the way down there at the bottom
it's hydrophobic by the way
in this class we do not say the words
hydrophobic interaction because that
doesn't make sense
there's no such thing as a hydrophobic
interaction
no hydrophobic interaction is misused
what it really means is that something
that's hydrophobic likes itself
more you know being together with itself
more than than it likes being in the
water
or something hydrophilic that's what is
meant but there's no actual interaction
there
okay hydrophobic hydrophilic those now
okay well those are other things you can
think about dissolving
you could also dissolve salt
and this is what we're going to use as
examples
and this is a picture of a salt crystal
so we showed the sugar
now here's salt now so the thing about
salt
where's my sugar there's the sugar and
let's put salt underneath it
the thing about salt
which is really just a general term for
when you have an ionic solid that
that can be made from a mixture of acids
and bases and dissolves
oftentimes a little bit at least in
water right
okay so so a salt uh let's see
a salt or like an ionic solid let's say
for now
okay this gives
something different because this breaks
apart
into positive and negative
ions
that they contain right so in the case
of sodium
and chlorine sodium chloride well that's
going to dissociate if you pour
salt in water then here's the reaction
for that you got sodium chloride solid
okay we put it in water that's going to
go into ions
okay so i put that in water it and it's
it's different in the sense that it
doesn't
break down into the molecules that made
up the sugar
does that have a particle of sugar
that's got millions and millions of
molecules in it
now they dissociate that's what the aq
means
okay those are neutral here they're it's
a
it's a solid but you can understand this
from looking at it and thinking about it
look at the way those water molecules
are oriented
right they're they're pointing to the cl
with their positivity
what positive charge and they're
pointing to their the sodium
with the negative and that's how they
find happiness
in water because they're ions
and water can be either way yeah it can
point its dipole in neither
and so it can actually bond remember the
hydrogen's got a little positive charge
because oxygen took it
right and so that's what the you know it
has a dipole and that's able to
to turn around and bond and be happy
with each of these ions that's why salt
dissolves
right because it can find a happy place
other reasons exist outside of this
class like entropy
thermodynamics
but this is how we're going to picture
it as energetically happy
it can become happy now
um okay so we've dissolved some things
we got to start thinking about the thing
that i mentioned before which is
how much can i dissolve how much can i
dissolve
and and that you know it gets into this
uh
this table here right okay there it is
so that's how much
and and you you see it's listed there as
moles per 100 grams
all right and so that's one way to write
it you could write it
as uh so so like it's often like the max
the max solubility
is often
what we're interested in and and you
could write it in in
uh okay moles per 100 grams you could
write it in
uh moles per liter well that's a
that's something that we've already
learned right that's m
from from last friday the molarity or it
could be in like grams
sometimes you'll see it in grams per
liter right so don't get
don't get bogged down but but you know
by the units
it's just how much of this stuff were
you able
to to dissolve and
and you know if we look at say sugar
okay here's sugar here's salt
how much sugar can dissolve okay
if you so
[Music]
i'll just i'm not going to cram it in
so for sugar
the max is
1800 so i'm going to
do both those units 1800 grams per liter
and if you convert that it's 5.26
moles per liter that's how much sugar
you can dissolve in water
by the way i did a quick calculation and
that's 429 teaspoons
that's 429 teaspoons i don't know what
everybody's saying
you know coke has so much sugar
coke's got only 26 teaspoons per liter
you could put a lot more in if they
wanted
i'll go the other way i challenge them
to go near the solubility limit
they're not even close too much sugar
so salt you can also look at salt okay
salt is uh
for salt what is it salt is 359
grams per liter and then that's it
that's 6.14
this is nacl
you know it's interesting if you compare
with sodium chloride with say sodium
bromide
right so if you look at sodium bromide
it's going to be 8.9
and sodium fluoride is only going to be
one
why because it comes right down to the
picture
i've got to make these happier i've got
to make them happier well
you got the ions there and the water
likes it but what if they really didn't
have as strong of an ionic bond to start
with we can imagine you might be able to
get to a higher
amount of dissociation oh what if they
had a very strong
ionic bond you might imagine that less
of it you got a lower
maximum solubility so it all kind of
goes together with the things that we've
learned
okay all right but what we're really
talking about
is what i need to tell you about next
and that is
this idea that we've reached a dynamic
equilibrium
we've reached a dynamic equilibrium so
what what does that mean well if it's
unsaturated
so if it's unsaturated i'm way before
this limit
right this is salt that's the limit max
max what does it mean
what does it mean to to be below what
does it mean to even have reached
the maximum itself okay
what it means is not that things aren't
dissolving
what it means is that things are
reforming recrystallizing
at the same rate that they're dissolving
that's what the maximum means and that's
an equilibrium and that's what we're
going to talk about next right
so if it's unsaturated there's a nice
little molecular picture right there's
the thing you're dissolving
and look at them they're going away into
solution
maybe it's salt breaking up into ions
maybe it's sugar
they're going into solution and finding
a happy place around the water but once
in a while one of them comes back you
see that
little particle there coming back that
happens but
but much more they're dissolving
then you reach this point of saturation
where it cannot where it's going to
recrystallize reform the solid at the
same rate that you dissolve and that's
the place
where you can't dissolve anymore
all right so what's really happening is
that you have a solute
plus a solvent and it's not
going one way as we've been dr uh
writing it down it's going both ways so
it's actually the solute plus the
solvent
goes like this that is what we've been
talking about that's dissolution
and that's the predominant mechanism on
the left before you've saturated
yeah but but see and that goes to some
solution
but see you can also precipitate
precipitate sun
precipitation right
and and so the sat at the saturated
solution you have
and if it's saturated
then that's another way of saying we've
reached the max
possible
concentration of the solute
remember little brackets means
concentration molarity
okay it means
that these rates thinking back to friday
are the same it means these rates are
the same
this is a dynamic equilibrium and so
that's what we need now
the tools to talk about and so we're
going to talk about three
three things the reaction quotient
the equilibrium constant k chemical
equilibrium and then the solubility
product okay now if you think about
react so
i just said this is like the forward
reaction is going in the same
it's happening in the same rate as the
reverse and so if you think about this
as like a graph okay
of concentrations so i'll just put here
concentrations right and time
then then maybe i have started i put my
my salt okay i pour a teaspoon of salt
in water
and and the the the salt is is
dissolving
right so so it's going into the products
it starts out at zero in solution and
then it becomes
products
okay but at the same time
maybe maybe i've started it up here and
these are the reactants because
in tight that look like this because in
time
and those would be the reactants
so the concentrations of these things at
a certain point they're changing
and then at a certain point they're not
changing
but there's still reactions happening
back and forth like i just showed you
it's a dynamic equilibrium
okay now what we do is we write down for
some arbitrary reaction
a a plus so let's go back to this one
okay
but now we're going to write it going
both ways
cc plus db
you can define the reaction quotient q
that's the first thing
as the concentrations a
c of the products c to the c
d to the d over
a to the a
b to the b please
do not confuse this with the rates
yeah i've been talking about like the
rates being equal
that's not from the rates remember the
exponents of the rate law
come from experimental measurements
the reaction quotient comes from the
stoichiometric coefficients
why the these these exponents here
have to do literally with probabilities
of reaction
of reacting it has to do with the fact
that if i've got
two of c then you multiply the amount of
c
times another amount of c in the same
volume
it has to do with probabilities of
reacting that's where you get those
exponents
and they're directly from the
stoichiometric coefficients they do not
need to be
experimentally measured once you have
this
you have the reaction quotient okay
now why is this useful this reaction
quotient well it's useful because
there's a very special place where
now it doesn't change anymore
these concentrations aren't changing
reactions are still happening but the
concentrations aren't changing
no change
if there's no change then gazoom type
then q isn't changing because it's just
a ratio of concentrations
it's a ratio of concentrations right
it's
equal to this whole thing not just the
top line
the reaction quotient
is related to the concentration so if
the concentrations don't change even if
reactions are happening still
it's a constant so at this point
q equals a constant
and that is an equilibrium constant so
we'll call it k
eq
it's a dynamic equilibrium k represents
a dynamic equilibrium
and what's really useful about k
is that for a given reaction k
is a constant i just said it but it
doesn't matter
for oh it depends on temperature but if
i keep the temperature fixed
k won't change it's a constant
it's it's it's the constant that tells
me
where equilibrium is it's a constant
that tells me where equilibrium is
okay now there's one more thing that we
got to write down
which is that third one there i'm going
to put it on here
so
so k is an equilibrium constant that's a
general constant
but now i'm going to turn my attention
from any old reaction
like k is actually a very general
concept for equilibrium
we are in this class going to use it for
solubility
that's how we are using the equilibrium
constant
no okay and so and so the ksp
is the solubility product
and it's an equilibrium constant
equilibrium constant
that is related to
solubility
it is literally the product of
solubilities in equilibrium that is
literally what it means so we're going
to do some examples to see that
it's an equilibrium so it's a constant
of equilibrium
and it's called the gazentite it's
called the solubility product because
it's related to
the equilibrium of dissolving something
dissolving some solute in a solvent so
we're going to do something
now we're going to do examples with
salts
okay so we're going to be dissolving
salts and talking about equilibrium
constants in that dissolution otherwise
known as the solubility product it's
just an equilibrium constant
there are many this is the one we're
going to care about and we're going to
do it for salts and so
one of the things you got to you know so
nacl that was kind of easy
right that became a cation and an anion
in solution
right yeah but salts can be made of many
many different types of cations and
there's
lists that go on and on and on um here
are some
and they get named right so here's like
some of the
the anions oh chlorine we just did that
one okay okay
uh bromine oh uh you could also have a
carbonate
you could have chromates hydroxides
oxalates sulfates sulfides
and then the list goes on and on and on
right there are many many of these
they don't have to be a single atom it
can be a part
of a salt that breaks off and has a
negative charge that's an anion and
here are some of the cations sodium
potassium calcium
right and you know about these things
we've been talking about these things
and you know like if it's sodium then
you know it's only going to lose it's
only going to be an a plus
it doesn't have a second weekly bond
bonded electron
to lose so it's really only going to be
an a plus
but but then you get and calcium is
going to be calcium 2 plus
right it's got two magnesium two and and
and then
iron you know transition metals a little
more complicated
right they can be a little more
complicated uh so like iron could be two
plus
or three plus or depends right and on
and on and on for those
right and and so so we'll do a few
examples
we'll do a few examples so we'll get our
kind of uh uh
you know we'll get into the mood
and i want to do it first i'm going to
do an example that's actually a classic
example because it's not it doesn't
dissolve
very well but it's silver chloride now
sodium chloride
is sodium chloride goes all the way
to the point where it it it basically it
dissolves
so well right
now so you can imagine the equilibrium
for sodium chloride goes way to the
right
yeah but for silver chloride it's it's
different for silver chloride it's
different
so we're going to look at this curve
okay and i'll talk about this curve
don't worry
we're coming to it we are coming to it
let me
start in the middle again because
what the equilibrium constant does given
the definition that i have just hidden
unfortunately
is it allows us to go back and forth if
i know the equilibrium constant
then i can get how much
one of these ions is soluble i can get
the solubility maximum solubility
of it right so let's take an example so
here here's a here's the question right
how much
a g cl cl
dissolves in
one liter of water that's
such a good question i don't know
but i do know that the solubility
product
that this equilibrium constant for
sodium chloride is 1.7
times 10 to the minus 10.
now if i write down the
the dissolution reaction sodium chloride
solid is going to go
to i'm sorry
sodium silver silver plus
in solution so we put the aqueous plus
chlorine
minus in solution okay
and it's going to go back and forth
and so the ksp for this is going to
equal
i'm going to go with the equation that i
wrote down the concentration of silver
to the 1
times the concentration of chlorine
minus these are ions
divided by the concentration of silver
chloride
solid
oh ho ho now we get to another thing
remember
i got rid of water because water's
everywhere
it's the solvent so you don't need to
put it into these equilibrium
calculations
yeah well it's the same thing with
the solid so if i
think about this a little bit this
equilibrium
is between dissolved
it's between the the ions that are
dissolving
but there from this from this reaction
from the way it's written there i've got
a solid form of silver chloride
so this is not so this is the
concentration
of solid silver chloride in the solid
that's just a constant that's not going
to change
that's not going to change common
misunderstanding
it doesn't change so we get rid of it
because it gets folded into the constant
that's always the same the concentration
of this
is always the same right and so we get
rid of it
so now we have the ksp k
is equal to in this case a g plus
times cl minus talk about solubility
product
concentrate right solubility is when
when i add this in it reaches some
equilibrium
where they're dissolving and reforming i
wanted to know at what point that is
what concentrations
is that going to be this is them
right and so solubility product right
there
now okay well that now oh
okay i used i used the definition of an
equilibrium constant
and now i can use this reaction
i can use this reaction because the
stoichiometric coefficients
tell me they tell me both what the
exponents there are
one but they also tell me the relative
molar amounts of these things is the
same
so if x equals the concentration of
silver plus
then it must also must
also equal the concentration
of cl minus if you just let x equal the
constant
that comes from the reaction one in
front of silver one in front of chlorine
and so that means now that you can solve
it because
x squared is equal to
one point seven times ten
to the minus tenth and
x equals 1.3
times 10 to the minus fifth
m and that equals these concentrations
right that equals the concentration of
silver plus so that is how much
in equilibrium this is an equilibrium
constant that is how much
you will get of these ions dissolved in
water
now there's a nice way to set this up
that um
that is taught is often taught in high
school i like it i think it's a good way
to kind of
keep track right and so if you were uh
wanting to keep track and you like
tables there's something called
the ice table now in this case it's
it's a little bit boring but
as you'll see it can actually wind up
being pretty useful especially when
we add other ions which are going to do
soon so ice is initial
change equilibrium initial
change equilibrium it's just a way of
keeping track of what i just did
because i started with some amount of
solid
okay and i had zero i put it into water
i had zero
but then i added 1.3
times 10 to the minus fifth and i added
1.3 times 10 to the minus fifth
and so my equilibrium is a little less
a little less
solid and over here
it's just these numbers okay
that was indeed boring but
have no fear it becomes helpful
and it becomes helpful because what
we're going to do next not right now
but on wednesday what we're going to do
is we're going to
we're going to mess with this
equilibrium we say
oh equilibrium i'm going to throw you
off an equilibrium and say no you're not
because i'm equilibrium and i will
always be found
and that's called le chatelier's
principle and and what that does is it
allows us to really go back and forth
we get to actually let's say add a bunch
of chlorine ions to this
and we're going to see what happens to
this balance
it will find equilibrium and we have the
tools now to know
how to find it that's that green curve
there you see this is what we're going
to work with
there's the concentration of chlorine
okay
now is it there's the concentration of
silver
in ions the dissolved chlorine on the
x-axis dissolve silver on the wax and
look at that
i've got that point b there
that is where these things have found
equilibrium
when it's not messed with now the thing
is
if you were a reaction happening and you
hadn't
gotten to equilibrium yet so i hadn't
added much silver chloride
if that was the case then you might be
at point d
does it notice that the reaction
quotient q
is less than the equilibrium quotient
the equilibrium constant
q is less that means it's going to be
driven to dissolve
more than it precipitates until it gets
to point b
on this curve you could also be way way
out
right with a much higher q point e and
you know
it's got to find equilibrium it's going
to find equilibrium which is what we
just calculated
those are the concentrations of
equilibrium it's got to get back to
point b it's going to do it by
precipitating out
solid it's gone too far
right but but you can see that
equilibrium can also be had and will be
had it
shall be had because k never changes if
you fix the temperature k is the same
so i can mess with this in other ways i
could go and add a whole bunch of
chlorine
and it will come back down onto that
green curve it will come back down onto
that green curve
which is the curve that guarantees k is
the same constant
that's what that green curve is okay
there's one last point i'm going to make
today
and that is units right units
of k
depend it was like the rate law it
depends
on the reaction
look a concentration is a concentration
that was deep units are capital m
moles per liter right but that means
that k
right k is is is two of those multiplied
together
so in this case k has
units of m squared
it must or it wouldn't work k
can have units of m cubed right
we will pick up here on wednesday and
we'll cover
more of this more examples before we
move on to acids and bases
you